those battles usually start with either
stunt team or the VFX team yes sir we
owe it to Sam Harker to create these
amazing starts for tight
[Music]
got a ring full
of movie stars got three franchise
carrying actors here this is our first
day here we are in Pinewood in Atlanta
and it's it's actually pretty
unbelievable you can actually engage in
this collaborative creative conversation
about what should this look like we
would show them our previous material
just let them know like these are there
certain things that you would be working
with to get to this final product it's
gonna look awesome when Chris doesn't
every character every hero involved
asked to use the highest level of their
power just is just to stay on the
battlefield with him big to Thanos for
his Iron Man big showdown this is death
all about some cool movies leading up to
right here you got a rep attending
junior josh brolin going hand to hand
right here Stark
how do you know my name I know your soul
it is much like mine cursed with
knowledge my only curse is you